Oh, sorry, immersion.
Oh, sorry, don't look at that.
Don't look at that.
There was a glitch in the matrix, guys.
I hate you, send to your meds in time chat.
There was nothing there.
Anyway, hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I am not looking forward to...
to the next part of Silent Hill, because I heard that the next section of Silent Hill is pretty fucking spooky.
Oh, why did I do this to myself?
I'm just... oh my god, why is this game so fucking scary?
I was... okay, I was actually...
I was actually, like, this close to UnSilentHill's Silent Hill.
I don't know if you guys saw the...
I don't know if you saw the mod, but somebody made a mod for Silent Hill where it just looks like a very nice city.
Like, it looks like a very... it looks like a... it looks like a nice town.
And I was... I was this close to downloading the mod, because I thought that was so fucking funny.
So basically, let me show you guys a picture of it.
Let me show you guys a picture, because I was like, oh...
Yeah, I was gonna... I was this close.
I need you guys to know, I almost did it.
I was almost that shameless to UnSilentHill's Silent Hill, because I was just so done.
I was... I'll show you the picture.
It was so good.
Oh my god, this is the picture chat of UnSilentHilling's Silent Hill.
So...
And then I saw the picture.
Wait, okay, let me see.
Oh my god.
And then somebody... somebody posted...
It looks so cozy.
I know!
It looks so nice.
It looks like such a nice town, chat.
Like, it just... it looks like...
And then there's a mod.
There's a... there's a mod that like...
That...
There's a mod that removes the fog.
And then I was like, bro, I won't...
I like... I like how the...
I like the... how the monster is just like, making my way downtown, moving fast.
Does it look so nice?
That's so wrong.
And then I almost...
There's another mod that removes the fog.
He's just out on the jog.
He's just out... just having a...
He's just doing... going through his day.
It looks... it just looks so much...
I don't know.
It just looks a lot cozy, you know?
He's just getting his groceries.
He's just doing his errands.
And I was this close...
Chat, I was...
I was this close to downloading both of those mods.
It's just... just for the sake of going...
Just for the sake of this...
Playing more of this game.
Anyway, Fiction for Eternity.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know if you're gonna see this.
I did, but I'm gonna keep trying until you see...
Oh, wait, I didn't see it.
Not a good user.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry, Doki.
I've confirmed the remake is only 10 times scarier than the OG game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was this close, chat.
I was honestly...
It was almost there.
It was almost there, but then I also got lazy too.
So my laziness won over the fact that like...
I could have made this game less scary for myself.
Also, if you guys didn't know...
Life update.
If you guys didn't know, I finally updated my Twitch emotes.
So I finally added Twitch emotes and animated...
Because I just got my animated emotes yesterday.
So I figured, you know, I was like...
Oh, I got my animated emotes.
I might as well.
So basically...
Let me see.
Where can I put this?
We have animated emotes now on Twitch.
Yay!
So not only do we have...
So this is one of my favorite anime emotes that we got.
Right here.
I think this one's my favorite, honestly.
It's like lip sync to shut up and take my money.
So this is one of them.
And then we have a second version of this.
So where he's like...
And then we have a part two version where he's just screaming.
He's like...
So we have two.
Both of these are on Twitch right now.
Unfortunately, YouTube doesn't have animated emotes.
But if you subscribe on Twitch, you can use these emotes anywhere on any channel.
So you know how YouTube emotes, you can only use it on my channel.
But on Twitch, you can use it anywhere.
So yeah.
So I'm really excited that we finally have them.
And since we finally have animated emotes, I figured like...
Since I have animated emotes, I might as well update all my other Twitch emotes.
So Twitch emotes are fully updated now.
Well, not fully.
I'm pretty sure I'm missing a couple of more emotes there.
But it's as updated as I could get yesterday until I got lazy.
James, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I could be walking around nice wet, but no.
Gotta suffer while I search for my dead bitch of a wife.
Thank you for the super chat, James.
Thank you, thank you.
You could have had it, James.
If only I wasn't so lazy.
If only...
Oh yeah, and then we have...
So yeah.
For those who don't know where I stream on Twitch, it's literally Doki Bird at Twitch.
So this is...
Life is live.
Anyway.
Let me see.
Originally, we were given...
Originally, for the monkey, we were given this one.
But I wanted to...
But then I figured you guys also wanted the classic monkey too.
So other than monkey spin, we have the classic monkey banana.
So we have both for all of you guys.
So you get both the spin and banana.
So we have nostalgia and spin.
And then we also have...
I like this one too.
I like...
Doki run.
So we have run as well.
So yeah, that's like a little update on what we have for...
What we have...
What we did...
What I did yesterday.
I did so much stuff.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, I think I can...
I think I can say a little bit about it because it's not technically not leaking.
But I saw...
I saw my nendoroid.
I'm so excited.
I saw...
I saw my nendoroid.
You guys are...
Ah, I can't wait.
Yeah.
I saw it.
I saw...
They sent me...
They sent me the prototype.
And I saw it.
And I'm super excited.
And I can't wait for you guys.
You guys are going to love it.
You guys are going to love the things I requested.
Because there was a lot of freedom on what I could request.
On what I want.
And oh my god, you guys are going to love what I requested.
You guys are going to...
So I'm super...
Well, I won't say...
I won't say what I put on there.
But I think you guys are going to be really happy.
I don't know when.
I don't know when it's actually going to be shown.
But...
Because I was sent the first prototype.
Like, pictures of it.
So...
So I can't wait.
I can't wait.
Yay!
Bounty Hunter...
It really depends on the sales of the first one.
So like, you guys...
If you guys really want the Bounty Hunter, you gotta buy 20.
If all of us...
If everybody buys at least 5 dendroids per person, maybe we can have the Bounty Hunt.
No, everyone buy 50.
So you can have a full party, chat.
You want to have a full party, right?
Or buy 3, so we can have a full Apex party.
Uh...
How is that a scam?
It's called...
It's called fucking...
What was it?
Demand...
Supply and Demand.
It's Basic Economics 101.
It's called Supply and Demand, chat.
If there's enough demand, then there's gonna be more supply.
P.S.A.
Don't listen to this mod.
Don't...
Spend reasonably.
Hahaha!
Reasonably is 5 dendroids.
That...
Buy 60, so you can fill up an entire Apex lobby.
Silent the stream.
Anyway, um...
I'm super duper excited.
Ah, there's so many...
Oh my gosh, my...
Like, guys, I tweeted about it.
But...
By the way, I'm stalling.
Um, I am not...
I am, uh...
I'm not...
I am shameless to tell you guys that I am stalling before I play Silent Hill 2.
Um, anyway, uh...
Anyway, um...
Oh, yeah, uh...
The next couple...
Oh my gosh, the next couple of months is gonna be so...
Not rough, but like...
Oh, I'm gonna be so fucking busy.
I...
I'm gonna tell you guys straight, like...
It's so packed.
The next couple of months regarding the stuff I have to do.
So, I hope you guys enjoy the final months of 2024.
I have so many things planned for you guys.
And I'm super duper excited.
Uh, whenever all the things eventually get announced.
Yay!
Um...
Fiction!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here's some more, so please hear my plea!
Can you play Spec Ops Align?
I want you to be one of us when it comes to the horrors of war.
What is that?
Oh, so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What the fuck is Spec Ops Align?
2012?
This game is alive?
Spec Align, the ops is no longer available on the Steam store.
Um...
What?
Uh...
I don't know, man.
I...
I don't know what to tell you, bro.
I don't know.
Like, I can't...
I can't fix Steam.
Um...
Delisted moment.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, thank you for the super chat.
Uh...
Wait, no way!
It got delisted due to musical reasons?
Oh, that's rough, buddy.
I'm sorry, man.
I'm...
I'm fucking sorry, man.
The goddamn music industry.
All right.
Yes.
I guess it's time.
I guess.
Okay, let me make sure my volume is okay.
Okay, let me save the sound settings for this.
I usually save sound settings for games that I think I'll play again.
So, I need to save this.
Uh, that's for Devour.
All right, and then where's my Silent Hill 8.7?
All right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
The worst part about this game is the fact that like...
James did not have to be such a fucking pervert.
Like, I...
James, if you were like...
If you weren't some fucking closeted freak, everything would have been fine.
If you were very open about what you like and what you want, James.
Like, if you were so open about...
He's a freaky freak.
Yes, that's the whole point.
Would you prefer the monsters to not be sexy?
I prefer the...
Okay.
I'm just saying is that if the...
If he was...
If he was, um...
If he accepted himself for who he was...
And didn't felt ashamed of his...
Of his kinks and fetishes, we wouldn't be here.
Okay?
That's all I'm saying.
We wouldn't be here if he wasn't such a...
If he wasn't so ashamed of himself.
I just need someone to match my freak.
You had Mary!
And then she died.
That's true.
But that...
There was the internet for a reason, James.
You have the internet to find somebody who match your freak.
Like, there is someone out there.
She was sick.
Yes, and she's dead.
And you have to find somebody else to match it.
Uh, thank you for the super chat, James.
Anyway, thanks for the super chat, James.
Thank you, thank you.
The mask stays on.
All right.
All right, so...
So we are back in the jukebox era.
The stupid jukebox era.
Wait, so Pyramid being a big buff half-naked man.
What did James mean by this?
Thank you for the super chat, Kaz.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, you don't know?
He sees himself as Pyramid Head.
In his own fantasy.
James sees himself as Pyramid Head of everything he's been trying to deny himself.
Pyramid Head is him, but free.
Like, he's his self insert.
Like, he's literally...
Oh yeah, I forgot I was also dying.
Pyramid Head is...
He wishes he was him.
Exactly.
He wishes he was Pyramid Head.
That's basically him if he was...
If he unleashes his beast form, his true form, he would be Pyramid Head.
All right.
Okay, guys.
I know I'm stalling this, but I actually need to get a cough drop.
I'll be right back.
We'll just look at the door, guys.
We'll look at the door.
I'll be right back.
Okay, I'm back.
All right.
I'm back.
I'm finished stalling.
Guys, I know you've watched 500 million streamers already got past this stage because I waited a bit too long to do a part two.
But you don't understand, guys.
It's Silent Hill.
Like...
I know you already might have seen 500 million other streamers already got through this stage of the game.
But like, now you're gonna watch me try and get past this stage of the game.
Now it's my turn.
Oh my god.
How do I heal again?
Guys, I don't remember how to heal.
What are my controls?
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
We're still stalling.
I don't remember the controls.
Give me a sec.
Okay, melee, dodge, space, reload, weapons.
Where the- They're struggling?
Where's heal?
Okay, V.
Okay.
All right.
Stop lock time, let's go.
I'm ready.
I'm so fucking ready.
Does that mean I can lock this?
Oh my god, where am I?
Where the fuck am- Why is it so dark, guys?
Okay, sorry.
I- I thought about this for a while.
Like-
Why do I have to make this thing so hard?
Guys, I'm sorry.
I thought about this and I figured...
Guys, no, you don't understand.
You don't understand.
I need it to be brighter.
Can I not make it brighter?
Okay, graphics.
Okay, guys.
Wait, there's no... I can't make the game brighter?
Are you fucking serious?
Okay, alright.
It's under Gamma Calibration.
Thank you.
Okay, guys.
Okay, there we go.
Guys, I'm sorry.
Like, I can't.
Please just let me have it be just a little bit brighter, you guys.
It's so dark.
I can't see the action, please.
Okay, that's a lot better.
Please, please let me have this.
Like, please.
That's all I ask.
Let me have this.
Fiction, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've been trying to ask you to play that game for months.
But you missed them all, including how you're gonna have to find an alternate way to play it.
Oh, no.
Is it legal?
Are the alternative ways legal, though?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, guys.
Like, I still want sponsors.
Guys, I don't want to piss off game companies, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Speaking of merch, have the YouTubes been shipped out yet?
I don't know, actually.
I should ask about that.
I remember when the estimated shipping was.
Does anyone remember?
It's been a while, so I don't remember.
November?
Oh, okay.
So next month.
I like that there's a little bit of sun here for now.
That's nice.
You came back after you left.
It's fine.
He didn't try anything.
He just seemed sad.
Mumbled about getting out of town with someone.
I wasn't gonna let him drive in his condition, so I locked him out.
His car should be out back.
Maybe check if it's still there by the morning.
It's a greenish-blue one.
Plate number ending with 06, I think.
Oh, this is the window I'm supposed to bash later.
Wait, then what's this?
Wait, what?
What?
Where was the car?
06.
Okay.
I just have to destroy the car.
Alright, guys.
I most likely will play 2 hours.
If I'm lucky, maybe.
If I'm lucky, 2 hours and 15 minutes.
Because I don't feel so...
I already don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good already.
Guys, I'm scared.
What do you mean?
I'm actually so scared.
I'm scared, guys.
Oh, no.
Wait, I can blame it.
Guys, I'm also sick.
No.
Guys, my tummy hurt too.
That's fine.
What do you mean lies?
I'm literally sick.
Guys, I actually have a good excuse.
It's just a game, Doki.
It can't hurt you.
Yes, it can.
This whole game is about mental pain.
And I'm feeling the mental anguish right now.
Oh, it's just a bug.
That's fine.
I swear, if it's just a bug and then the actual monster comes out and bashes my head.
I swear to fucking god.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nope, bad.
Bad, nope, nope.
Oh, don't make me use it.
I've killed many.
I've killed many of my imaginary friends.
They're not real, so it's not murder.
Just so you guys know, they're not actually real.
Look out, Doki, behind you!
Where's the other one?
Oh, what the fuck?
You trying to sneak behind me, you little bitch?
That's right.
I ain't afraid of you.
Fuck these cars.
God, I should have downloaded the remove mods.
Shit.
I should have downloaded remove the fog.
Like, at least maybe if I got rid of the fog...
Things would have been better for me.
Oh my god.
Dan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is there more meds?
Any more meds?
Hello?
Any more sick people in Silent Hill?
I request more sick people in Silent Hill which I can rob.
Dan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The original had a...
Had a screen noise effect that made the game look grainy like a film.
It's absence in this remake saddens me.
This game is too pretty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh no, thank god this game is too pretty.
At least it's less scary, right?
I like how you're willing to play this game but not Dead Space Remake and it's less scarier.
Friend, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I did though.
And we finished it.
Dude, Dead Space Remake is a lot less scary than this game.
No, no, no, you can't...
As somebody that played all the Dead Spaces, it is less scary.
Because I have a fucking...
Oh look, just as I... I have a gun.
But like, the guns don't work.
Because the monsters in Dead Space, they stay dead.
But the monsters here don't stay dead.
Are you fucking...
Are you...
No, no, no.
No, no.
Get out, get away, get away.
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright.
You fucking...
Oh, it didn't hit me.
Oh, it didn't hit me, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, that's good, that's good, that's good, that's good.
And then he's fucking crawling like a little...
Oh god!
Try to be a goddamn...
How is a...
Nobody loves you!
Not even your parents, and that's why you're orphans.
Okay.
There we go.
Shouldn't you just run away?
Yes, but I need loot.
I can't run away when there's all these cars out there.
But like I was saying...
As I was saying, I think...
I think Dead Space is less scary than Silent Hill 2.
Than Silent Hill 2 right now.
Because in Silent Hill 2...
I'm not a fighter, but in Dead Space I am.
So...
It's a lot easier to deal with, because I can just shoot them and then it's fine.
But...
I can't...
I can't fucking shoot these fuckers!
Okay.
Yeah, it's spookier too.
I'm not supposed to go now.
Oh my god, where...
Wait, which apartment?
There?
Main street?
Where am I?
Guys, I can't read them.
Oh, wood side apartments.
Oh, back there!
How the fuck do I get there?
The red square?
Where are my items?
Oh, fuck me, I didn't get a chance to read that!
Okay, sorry.
I didn't get a chance to read the key I got after getting fucking ran at.
Like...
Like, my bad!
Like, how was I...
I was told that there was no pauses when you're on the map.
I was fucking told there was no pauses.
Like, what the fuck was I supposed to do?
Oh my god.
Guys, how was I supposed to read in this condition?
Like, with all these fuckers just...
With all these fuckers!
Just there.
How am I supposed to read?
Alright.
Is this it?
They're still following me.
Jesus Christ, stop.
Alright.
They shouldn't follow me now.
I'm inside.
Nice.
They shouldn't follow me now.
This is like a safe space, right?
Alright, and now I'm here.
Okay.
Oh, there it is.
It is safe.
Okay.
Okay, thank god.
God!
Thank god.
Okay, it's still safe.
JL, how much for four hours instead of two hours?
Thank you for the super chat, JL.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I don't think you can afford it.
Truthfully, I don't think you can afford my four hour fee.
Okay.
What is this?
Is this more meds?
Oh, thank god.
Oh, wait.
Handgun ammo for a gun I don't have.
Oh my god.
What's this?
Oh, it's the puzzle.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Three bright coins in the five holes be.
First sits the maiden underneath the tree.
The wind passed the bet.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What if we paid 200 per hour?
Then you just need to pay 400.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
The wind from behind the maiden doth blow.
A beautiful flower alone has to grow.
And here comes the man, so sleek and so fine.
In the pale moon...
That wasn't me agreeing to it.
I did not agree to the deal.
I was just stating a fact.
I was just stating numbers.
In the pale...
We didn't even have a contract here, guys.
There was no negotiations nor contracts.
And here comes a man, so sleek and so fine.
In the pale moonlight, his eyes doth shine.
Alright.
So, I have to find six of these.
Oh my god.
Bro.
I can't even...
Okay, there we go.
10 out of 10.
I need...
It's over, bro.
She's learned not to take benefits of us.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Why am I in a confined space?
Why am I in a...
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Raise the count.
Why am I in a...
Oh my god.
I think that's the worst part.
I'm in like a confined area.
Like, and I don't even have a fucking flashlight.
Where's the flashlight?
How the fu...
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, I did not get everything?
Why is it still circled?
Did I not get everything in this room?
What am I missing in this room?
Is it worse?
Yes, this is worse than Ashley.
Cause like I said, like, even when you have a gun in this game.
Cause like, I didn't ever...
This is my first Silent Hill game.
But...
Oh, it's telling me where the puzzle is.
Oh.
Okay, even though...
Like, I know stuff about Silent Hill.
And like, even though this is like...
Um...
Even though this is like a...
This is my first Silent Hill game.
Like, guns doesn't matter.
Guns don't fucking matter.
Like, it doesn't fucking matter in this game.
Like, it doesn't matter if I shoot them.
They just come back alive.
Like, what's the point?
What's the point of your shooting?
If they just fucking live?
Like, I might as well just chuck my gun at them.
Like, it's just a waste of precious time.
Nice.
Got more ammo.
That's not killing if it's temporarily.
That's just me fucking staggering them.
Like...
It's...
It's not...
That's not what kill means, guys.
Kill means they're dead.
That's not what kill means.
Kill means...
Sayonara.
Goodbye forever.
Yuki, dad said he wants to play...
Wants you to play 4 hours for us.
Well, he wants a lot of things.
And if I give him all of these things, he...
He would not...
He would not be okay.
Some would say I would be a very bad owner.
Are you serious?
The fuck was that?
What the fuck was that?
I had a bet with you in Overwatch 2 a few streams ago.
So since I do not know if you made top 500 this season, you can be forced to play 4 hours this instead to make us both suffer.
Wait, what was the bet?
Oh, no.
Wait, what was...
What was our bet?
Wait.
I actually know.
Okay, if you...
Okay, if we both don't remember the bet, it's okay.
None of us remember what the bet is.
It's okay.
Thank you again for the...
I really appreciate it.
And we stay dead in buildings with a few...
What are the exceptions?
You can't stay with a few exceptions and then don't name the exceptions.
What does that mean?
How would I know which one is the exception?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Oh, my God.
I hate this game so much.
This game...
This game will be the fucking...
Oh, it's the mannequins.
No, it's the fucking...
Oh, my God.
No, not the mannequins.
Oh, I know what this is.
I know what this is.
No.
Here's my flashlight.
It's the sexy legs.
James, I know you like legs.
James.
Oh, my God, James.
Why?
Oh, my God.
The fucking sexy legs.
Oh, hey.
Are those Mary's clothes?
Bro, if you love...
Oh, my God.
No wonder you're so...
No wonder your desires are so fucking suppressed.
Is this what Mary dressed like?
And then you're like...
It's like a Victorian girl.
You see a Victorian girl show a little bit of ankle?
And now all your monsters are just sexy legs.
Like...
When your fucking wife dresses like it's in the Victorian era and now you're fucking...
You're fucking...
You see an ankle and now you're...
This is all you see now.
This is...
This is all you see.
God damn it, James.
Damn it.
Oh, my God.
He just knows what he likes, guys.
He fucking knows what he likes.
Do I need to heal or should I get damaged a little bit more?
You know what?
I respect it.
Wait, where's like...
They punish him.
They punish him with a good time.
Don't...
Okay.
Should I heal now or should I wait until...
Should I heal now or should I wait until I'm damaged a little bit more?
I'm mad at James.
God damn it, James.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, I assume it's like...
I assume it's downstairs.
The shoot courtyard key.
I assume that's what it means.
Okay, maybe here?
No, that's not it.
Oh, it's the other side.
God, I don't feel so good.
I don't...
I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good, James.
I'm gonna save just in case, James.
I'm gonna save.
I don't trust you, my dude.
I don't...
Wait, did they remove that scene?
Did they remove the infamous pyramid head scene?
Then we'll actually know if it's Gooning Hill.
We'll know.
What?
They didn't?
Alright.
Oh, they did?
Poor pyramid head.
Poor James.
Even in the remake, his desires remain suppressed.
Okay, I guess we'll go this way.
What the fuck is in James' head?
Let him be free!
His wife is dead!
Literally, this is all he asked for.
His wife is fucking dead.
Let him be who he is.
Please,
he has nothing.
Stop judging him!
Warning, garbage chute out of order.
Do please not use until the problem is resolved.
Bro, there's so many problems.
What the fuck?
Let me through!
Here?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Question mark.
Did it look at the trash?
Oh, there it is!
Okay.
Where's the entrance?
Wait a minute, where am I supposed to go?
Give me a sec.
I need to know where I'm supposed to go.
I need to know where the entrance is.
There's an open window?
Oh shit, there's an open...
I should not be needing this.
I should not be needing this to go through an open window.
This is a problem.
You need to build up your upper body strength if you need an open window for this.
Oh my god.
Buried two inches in his neck.
Oh Jesus Christ.
At least get a fucking fork.
Oh my god.
He's trying to kill me.
He's trying to punish me.
That monster.
The red devil.
Forgive me.
I did it.
But it wasn't me.
I guess now that I think of it...
About it.
He was kinda cra...
Oh, just a little bit, you know?
Like...
Yeah, just...
You know.
Talking about the red devil.
Seems a little pretty fucking silly, you know?
Just a little silly.
Just a little bit odd.
But we didn't think much about it.
We're just like...
Oh, look.
Look at that silly Walter.
Saying all these things again.
Let's see.
Oh wait, is this open?
Oh my gosh, thank god.
Why would you do this?
Why would you bait me with the option of opening and you don't even give me the meds?
How could you do this to me?
How?
Alright.
Well, at least I get ammo.
Just a little bit.
He's just a little silly.
I don't know what else to say.
Not again.
Where would he be in?
He's outside, isn't he?
Oh my god!
Okay.
He tried to sneak up to me, but I heard the sound.
Let's...
Come on, Doki.
You got this.
Come on.
It's just a door.
You got this, Doki.
It's just...
It's just a door.
Alright.
Here we go.
We're here.
We're here at the door.
Oh, I wish this was Red Dead Space instead.
Guys, I wish this was Dead Space.
Here we go.
Here we fucking go.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, there you are.
Okay.
Bro, I'm not stupid, bro.
Get out.
I...
Get out!
I am a man of God.
Do not tempt me, you seductress.
Do not tempt me.
That's right.
Hellfire.
How did he see me?
Okay.
Let's go.
Where are we?
Oh.
Oh, there's handgun.
Nobody can tempt me now.
Let's see.
Just in case.
Be gone.
Be gone, seductress!
Be gone!
I am a man of God.
You can't tempt me into the world of sin.
Alright.
I guess that's it.
That's all?
That's everything in this place?
Okay, I guess it was.
I guess it was everything.
Just wanted to be sure.
Go back at it again.
Here we go.
Don't listen to Toki.
Dude, tempt me.
Jeez, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, I got an achievement for opening a locked door.
For trying to open a locked door.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
The hell?
Wait, what?
That was pointless.
Did I get anything?
No.
Is there another window?
The fuck?
What was the point?
What the fuck was the point of that?
There's nothing there.
I got ammo.
That's all I got.
That was literally everything.
The shortcut to what?
Was there supposed to be a mystic item?
Where was the item?
Mystic item?
Oh, it's over there.
Fucking hell.
Alright, grab that key.
The placement of that enemy is concerning because it was in the bathroom for me.
The jumpscares are spot...
Oh!
Why is there a child here?
Who fucking left this child here?
This is not up to code.
No children should be here.
Goddamn children.
Yeah, what the kids do... That's exactly what I'm saying, James.
Not what the fuck do I do.
That was literally...
Fucking children.
Oh, goddamn child.
Oh, that child is so mean.
Whose child is this?
What the fuck do I do now?
I guess like, I go on...
But I don't have that...
It's unlocked now?
Maybe it's unlocked now.
Maybe that area is unlocked.
Right?
I assume it is.
I'm gonna save just in case.
The fuck?
Okay.
Okay, it is.
It is.
Alright.
Now the place is unlocked.
Okay.
The fuck?
Wait, does that mean this area is unlocked too?
Oh, it is.
Oh, nice.
Sweet.
Alright.
I guess I'll go to all these other rooms.
Oh.
Where is he?
He's here.
He's here somewhere.
Oh, he's here.
He's here.
I know you're here.
Get over here.
I'm gonna fucking put this down inside your head.
Oh, that's right, child.
I mean, monster.
I'm talking about the monster.
I'm just, I'm just shimmying over there.
I'm almost there, guys.
Oh, I'm almost there.
We're almost there.
We're gonna make it.
Okay, but before I do that...
Let's beat up some legs.
Where are the legs?
Where is the seductress here to tempt me?
Where are you?
I know you wanna tempt me again.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, hey.
Where is she?
Where are the legs at?
I was so prepared to get tempted.
I was ready.
I was ready to let her try.
What the fuck?
She doesn't even wanna try?
Bro, I could've...
What?
She doesn't even wanna try?
My biggest fear, a child.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Why doesn't she wanna try?
Oh, it's a wedding dress.
Is that my wedding dress?
I mean, my Maria?
Huh?
Alright, here we go.
Here we go, back at it again.
Here we go.
We're gonna make it eventually.
This is it.
Alright.
Legs?
No legs?
Okay.
Oh, I guess I'll grab the key.
Second floor, hallway key.
Okay, that's for second floor.
Alright, that means there's a monster right here.
The legs has to be here, the seductress.
She has to be here.
Where else would it be?
Einstein Blumen, okay.
Where else would she be tempting me from?
My god, it's so quiet.
I think this is what I don't like.
It's either like the spookiest fucking ambient noises ever, or it's so quiet.
And then like, I'm so like nervous right now.
I'm very nervous.
It's like way too quiet.
Bro, I played Fortnite.
I'm using Fortnite strats right now.
Bro,
what the fuck?
At least there's medicine there.
God, I hate this at all.
My god, my heart.
If I had a heart monitor on right now, my heart is like through the roof right now.
I'm so fucking... oh my god, I'm so...
Oh, that's the child I'm gonna fucking find.
I'm gonna find her.
Okay.
Alright, no seductress here.
No legs to tempt me and to tempt me to sin.
No Adam and Eve scenario.
That's good to know.
Can Adam and Eve this, bitch?
Oh hey, the door's open.
Hey, the door was never open before.
Wait a minute.
God.
Okay.
Hello?
No, it's not the same, guys.
He's not... it's not the same, guys.
You wanna throw up?
Watch this.
Oh!
Okay, I need him to throw up first.
There we go.
That's right!
Ha!
Okay, dodge, dodge, dodge.
That's right, I know your pattern now!
That's right!
I figured out your pattern, you bitch!
That's right.
I figured it out.
Nice.
Oh, now I can go here.
Ooh.
Is there legs here?
Is there legs?
Any legs?
Any...
Any more temptations?
Anyone else want to tempt me right now?
Yeah?
Anyone else wants to tempt me into sin?
Oh, no.
Okay, we're good.
Okay.
Okay, none.
That's good.
We don't have to deal with more.
Alright.
Please deliver this to Mrs. M...
What the...
What the fuck?!
I'm trying to read!
I really read!
Don't ruin this for me!
Don't...
What would your Silent Hill monsters be?
I'm already living through it right now.
Mistakes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's all I need.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
EversleepyVodWatcher here.
Just popping in the super chat.
Make sure we're still staring at the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm really worried about her.
She's been cooped up all along with his belongings for days on end.
She won't even move them.
And God forbid anyone else touch anything.
It's breaking my heart just thinking about it.
Unlucky.
Poor guy.
Just in case.
Oh, can't have no sinners here.
No sinners in my area.
Alright.
Oh my God.
We're okay.
I'm pretty sure this has to be...
Do we...
I'm pretty sure the apple goes up there.
That's where the apple should be going to.
Alright.
I have the key to the second...
I don't know if I should...
Should I even go through...
Do I go upstairs first or...
Or go through that area, chat?
Like, do I go upstairs or do I go through, like, the hallway of pain?
Like...
Kid, thank you for the super chat.
The hallway of my...
Of my inner dark thoughts.
Thank you for the super chat.
Kid, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, but I have the key.
I have the second floor hallway.
Which one should I go first?
I don't know if I should go through the hallway of my inner dark thoughts or, like, the second floor.
Can't tell.
Which one should I do, chat?
Is it through that hallway?
Is it through the hallway right now?
The hallway I'm looking at at the moment?
Where...
Where all the...
The sexy ladies are dancing over there?
Where are you co...
Oh, neither.
You know neither.
I'm...
Okay.
Alright.
We're gonna go through the hallway of fucking ladies.
I'm gonna...
The freaky hallway.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Guys, I've been hydrating a lot, okay?
I'll be right back.
I'm just gonna use the bathroom.
I'm back, guys.
I actually turned on the lights.
I turned on multiple lights.
In my...
In my apartment.
Just...
Just for this.
I had...
I had to.
I...
I couldn't.
Oh, my God.
It's too dark outside.
It's too...
It's too dark in this game.
Alright.
Time to go through the hallway of my inner dark...
Where did they go?
Where did my...
Where did my freaks go?
Oh, there they are.
I knew you guys wouldn't leave me.
Get over here.
Let's get freaky right now.
Yes, I...
Guys, I need you guys to know.
My electricity bill is gonna...
Go up now because of this.
But it's worth it.
Oh, I had a feeling.
Yeah, he's charging it up.
He's charging it up again?
Oh, my God.
Is he charging it up again?
That hits me?!
Oh, no.
There's no more Mr. Nice Guy.
Can't believe that hits me.
I'm fucked up.
I planned it and everything.
Does he go through this?
Oh, he does.
Okay, just in case.
Yes, I knew it.
I knew it.
Like, now I'm paranoid.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Are you fucking crawling now?
You're crawling?
You're fucking crawling?
Okay, I'm a little...
I'm a little...
I'm a...
You don't make me happy.
You didn't follow the script.
So, I'm a little peeved.
You were supposed to follow the script, bro.
Alright, any legs?
Any legs in here?
Any...
Any singles in my area?
Okay, nice.
Another health drink.
Any single ladies in my area?
Alright, here we go.
Oh, I didn't open this.
It didn't matter.
Okay, I feel like I should heal.
I feel like I should heal.
I'll do it.
Alright, off we go.
Off we go to 101.
Okay.
Is that it?
Is that really it?
I only had a one...
Okay.
Why...
Why did I have to go here?
What was the point?
Okay.
That's alright.
That's okay.
I lost HP just to heal again.
Got back the health drink that I lost.
Please don't tell me I missed an item in there.
I didn't miss an item, right?
Did I?
I don't know.
Cory, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
First time I finished Silent Hill 2, we had Tornado Drill Siren go off in the neighborhood on a foggy day.
I cried and hid for an hour.
You got this, Toki.
Oh my god.
I'm glad you're okay, bro.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
There was a gun in there?
Where?
I got back into the freaky hall.
Please don't come back to life.
I missed an important item.
Where could you place a gun?
Oh my god.
It's a photo.
I thought this was it.
But it's just a photo.
No guns here.
It's an upstairs?
Then why'd it have to go here?
Why did I have to be here?
This was all for a fucking photo!
Oh my god, this was all for a goddamn photo.
I can't believe it.
I can't...
I can't believe I came back for a fucking Valentine's Day photo.
Believe it!
This is my anger management class.
I can't fucking believe it.
Okay, up I go.
Alright, here we go.
I guess the gun is here then.
I
guess the gun has to be here.
Okay.
There's so many rooms.
How many rooms are there?
What the fuck?
Why did I kill this guy?
Why did I kill you?
I don't remember this.
Oh no, did I black out and did this?
It's Pyramid Head.
It has to be him.
It's him.
I didn't do this.
Unless I did black out.
That can't be me.
I didn't do this.
That has to be Pyramid Head.
Hello?
Me?
Guy I wish I...
The guy...
My fantasy ideal self.
God, I'm so paranoid just walking through these halls.
Oh, there he is!
There's me!
Hello?
Hey!
I'm you!
Oh my god, look at that hunk of a body you got there.
That's my true peak form right there.
Hey there!
Can I change my hat?
Hey!
We're just to save.
You are not...
At least he's friendly.
Hey!
Bro!
That's me!
I mean, you and I...
Alone in this apartment.
Nobody here to bother us.
One of us has to change.
Just the two of us.
It's like looking in the mirror.
Yeah!
It's there like looking in the...
What is he just standing there?
It's not even scary.
He literally is just...
Standing there.
Feels weird.
He's just like there.
Like...
This is so awkward.
Like he's just...
Like...
What?
Don't come in?
Do you wanna...
Do you wanna come in here?
I don't know.
Alright.
Oh, this is where the legs lady is.
No?
I don't understand.
Why is he just there watching me?
Like...
Does he not wanna...
He's on strike.
Like I'm just wondering if he wanted to hang out.
You know?
Like clearly we both have something in common.
Like we both have...
Pyramids as heads.
Just thought he would just wanna hang out, you know?
Just...
You know, relate to each other.
How about we just be super relatable?
What's this?
What?
What is that?
I don't fucking know what I just looked at.
That's a wall.
Why are there scratches on the wall?
I'm just like, that's a wall.
Something was supposed to be there, yeah.
Who knows?
Okay, you can't smash the wall.
You can?
I don't think I can.
See?
Can't slap it.
Guess I'll go through this deep dark hole.
Okay, if I go through that...
Then I have 214...
Why is he just watching me like that?
It's just weird.
I just don't like it.
I'm like, he's just staring at me.
Like...
It's just weird.
Like, he's just...
He doesn't even do anything.
Like, yeah, I know, we're both handsome.
You're literally me.
We gotta keep that in the bedroom, bro.
Due to the ongoing renovation works, tents are asked to keep...
Oh, the third floor of the building.
Okay.
Oh.
Toki, when someone matches her freak.
Papa, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't know, I just feel like...
His entrance should be a little scarier.
Instead, he just...
He's just...
I don't...
Is it...
I don't know.
Is that...
Is that just me?
I feel like, you know, his entrance should be just a little scarier.
Instead, he's just...
He's literally just...
He's just standing there watching me.
But he is you, James.
Exactly.
He is you.
Like, he's just the default standing man.
I'm like, I don't know what you want me to do, bro.
Like...
Alright.
Well, there's a lot of bullets here, so I assume...
Oh, hey, there's another ammo here.
James, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Man, if I was a fraction of the hotness of Pyramid Head, I'd have so many more...
Oh, James.
Oh, no, my cop drop.
My cop drop broke.
Goddamn, I blame you, James.
This is your fault.
Wait, where did I drop my cop drop?
Oh, fuck.
I don't know where it went.
Oh, well.
Alright.
What does this do?
Now what?
Oh, hey.
Okay, there's a door here.
Um...
Oh, do I shoot it?
I might as well just shoot it, right?
Alright.
Now what?
Alright, is this like Resident Evil where I have... where headshots don't matter?
I need to know now.
Because I have, like...
You know, if I hold it, I need to know.
I can...
Before I waste bullets.
I need to know.
Okay, it's like Resident Evil.
Okay.
Alright, that's good to know.
Headshots don't matter.
You're right.
They sort of don't have a head.
I forgot.
It's just literally legs.
Like...
You're right.
How do I swap weapons?
Guys, how do I swap weapons?
I'm, like, stuck on my gun.
Burrito, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
I can't... How do I swap weapons?
Chat.
Oh, I only shoot while aiming?
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
I tested it out.
What do I do?
Where am I?
Wait, what do I do now?
Guys, where do I...
Where do I go?
Gang, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where do I...
Where do I go?
I'm stuck.
212?
Okay.
Oh, wait, there's TVs on.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, when was the TV on?
Oh, she's definitely dead.
Where did you get here?
Do it, you coward!
Do it!
Is that me?
Wait, that's my pants.
How did you get here?
Oh, hey, 212.
Oh, now you're scared.
You killed so many hot, sexy legs today.
But one blanket you couldn't lift.
That seems to be me.
Those are my pants.
And my shoes, see?
We have the same shoes.
Oh, that's me.
I died?
It has to be me.
That's literally my pants and shoes.
He's just missing the hat.
Oh, he knows it's me.
Oh, he's gone.
Oh my god, my sexy self is gone.
My dream ideal body.
I swear to god, I swear to god, if I fucking see you, I swear to god I'm ready.
I'm ready, you fucking seductress.
Oh, I'm so ready.
You goddamn sexy fool.
Okay.
Okay, she's not here.
Okay, we're good.
We're good.
I have to be sure, guys.
Okay, there's nothing outside.
Seduce this freak.
Okay, now that I'm outside, I feel less scared.
Alright, now I'm inside again.
Now I'm scared.
Okay, that was like a quick five seconds.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Not good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun fact, it's an evil James who was replaced by Pyramid Head.
Hence why Pyramid Head killed him off screen.
His jacket was red.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Oh, he's here.
Wait, is that her?
Oh shit, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
That was so funny.
I was just like, wait, he has two legs.
He never stops.
I'm just like, what is he doing there?
I was like, wait a minute.
This doesn't seem right.
Something's wrong with this picture.
Alright, any more?
Like, he was just standing there.
Bro was playing dress to impress.
Literally dress to impress and I just came over here and be like, just shot her in the leg.
Okay.
Anything back here?
No, that's just a fucking wall.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Did he even hit me?
I can't tell.
Okay.
That was pointless for that guy.
I was just like, my wife!
I shouldn't waste ammo.
But it'd be funny.
Oh, that hit me!
Are you fucking- Okay, that's karma.
That's actually karma.
I didn't think that would actually hit me, guys.
I didn't think this through.
Oh shit, that must be a shortcut.
Guys, I didn't think it through, guys.
I don't know if you noticed that.
I didn't think it through.
I just thought it'd be funny.
Hot lady?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, welcome home!
Oh shit!
That's right!
Happy birthday!
This is my birthday you shouldn't have!
Oh, what?
Bro, no, no, no.
Don't get on your knees, please.
No, don't, don't.
I'm a man of God.
Guys, I know it's my birthday, guys, but please.
I promised.
Bro, bro, it's not even my actual birthday, bro.
Oh, hey.
Oh, nevermind.
I was like working late.
Oh, nice, more ammo.
To be fair, I would like more HP instead of ammo, though.
Not gonna lie.
Okay.
Heads to 205.
Oh, destroy the balloons if I want.
Nobody deserves happiness.
Oh.
Okay, I can't.
Guys, you liar.
I was going to.
He just wants to help his bro out.
Wait, what?
What's the point of going outside?
I'm not gonna waste my bullets.
Like, does it give me anything?
Guys, I'm not gonna waste my bullets, guys.
Doki is for fresh air.
I'm bragging rights.
Which way do I go again?
Okay, straight.
Bro, I know we're like best friends, bro, but like, bro.
I'm sorry.
Just don't swing that way, bro.
That's why you got the legs, lady.
Was it?
Oh, okay.
Bro.
Just wanted to help a bro out, bro.
You must think I'm cruel, but this prison is of your own making.
The choice was yours.
I've watched you make it over and over and over again.
This time's not gonna be any different.
And I'll be here.
Watching.
Oh, bro.
Bro, I'm sorry for rejecting you.
Wait.
The fuck?
What is this?
Is this my little peephole?
Whose hole is this?
Who lived here?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, he was watching something.
Somebody in here.
How do I get there?
Is 205 open now?
Chat?
I assume 205 has opened up, right?
I can push it?
Oh, I can!
Oh, there we go.
What?
What happened?
Oh, that fucking thing!
Okay.
Nice poem.
Oh, no.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Seven.
Okay, let me read this poem again.
Okay, so...
The second number is seven.
There's a seven here.
What's the next number?
What the fuck?
I only found one number!
Eleven.
Okay.
Okay, that's the last number.
Seven and eleven is the last number.
So...
Okay, it's blank, seven, blank, blank, eleven.
Cause that's the river.
Should be...
Thirteen.
Thirteen, seven.
We need one more.
Has he found home?
Oh, please pray tell.
What's the last number?
Thirteen, seven.
And then, blank, eleven.
Where's the last number?
Where is it?
I'm looking everywhere!
Is it only three numbers?
Nothing is highlighted.
Oh, I got all of them?
Okay, thirteen, seven, eleven.
Okay.
Thirteen...
Seven...
What?
Thirteen...
Oh.
Seven...
Eleven.
What?
That's not how you do it?
Did I mess it up?
Thirteen...
Seven...
Eleven.
Oh, there we go.
I messed it up.
Yeah, I messed it up.
Oh, my jaw and head.
If only I could see what that says.
Whoa.
Guess we'll never know.
Alright.
Nice.
That was an easy fucking puzzle.
After I go out of here...
I guess I can go out...
I go to 205?
And check that out.
And then...
I'm already sort of low-key lost, not gonna lie.
Like, I don't remember where I've been and where I haven't been.
Like, where am I at this point?
I don't know.
Oh.
Alright.
It's my birthday again?
Hello?
Oh, there's a little chair.
I don't like the implication of that chair.
Is that...
Oh, I don't like the...
Cause it could be a good chair or a bad chair.
Is it my birthday chair or is it like...
My wife's birthday chair?
Oh, shit!
Sorry, I got distracted.
Oops.
I...
Okay, I got...
And you know you know.
Alright.
I'm not sure what that even means.
Okay, that's good for you.
That's good for you.
You don't want to know.
I missed an item?
I missed a fucking bug.
That's what I missed.
Oh, I did miss an item.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff here.
Might as well hydrate real fast.
I just don't like being like low HP.
It freaks me out a little.
How do I go this way?
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Oh, it's a shortcut.
Yeah.
Should I save?
I feel like I should save.
I'm gonna go save.
Just in case.
Hey, guys.
Happy.
What the fuck?!
How are you still alive?!
Oh, my God.
Get out of here.
I'm trying to save my game.
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
go ahead to save my game.
Alright, that didn't scare me that much because I knew that I had a feeling one of them came back to life.
Because it started being like danger, danger, stranger, danger.
And I was like, oh, okay.
So, like, I had a feeling.
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling things weren't gonna go so well.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna go put this in the hole.
Put this in the hole.
I can move it around later.
I just want it to be there.
Yeah, because I was like, stop.
I'm just like, stop.
God.
Nobody wants you here.
This is why nobody invited you to the welcome home party.
Alright, up I go.
I'm pretty sure I am like...
I could be doing this a lot faster.
But there's a lot of things I could be doing.
Definitely feel like I could be doing...
I would have been done with this level a long time ago.
Oh.
He's supposed... he's not supposed to be there.
Hello?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I mean...
I mean, he's just gonna...
He's just gonna run like that, I guess.
Alright, there we go.
I was like, just vomit!
He's just walking there.
Please.
He's just...
He's just trying to hang out.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my God, it disintegrated.
That's some fucking old-ass block right there.
Alright.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God there's a safe.
Where do I go?
Can I even go downstairs?
Wait, which way?
I guess I go up?
I guess so.
Oh yeah, there's a door here.
Oh my God, how big are the apartments?
How big are these...
How many more rooms must I go into?!
Oh my God.
There's like four fucking... I need like...
Four to five more fucking medallions!
Medallions!
Oh my God.
I feel like I'm gonna be here forever.
Oh, there you are.
Ah,
fuck!
Oh shit!
That's fucking right!
Whoa!
That's... I'm done.
I was done.
I was over here with that shit.
Oh shit, sorry.
I was too...
No more playing around.
No more...
No more playing around here.
You dodge, I bring the gun out.
Dodge this.
That fight wasn't fair, Toki.
Yeah, and the 3v1 was not...
Okay, and what about that 3v1 that they try to do?
Huh?
Like, what about that?
If you're trying to say that wasn't fair.
They literally tried to 3v1 me.
Okay.
They did have guns, though.
Okay, nice.
I got back some of the ammo I used on these girls.
They are just legs.
Yeah, but they wanna kick me.
What did I do to them?
I literally did nothing.
Is there anything back there, just in case?
Just items?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
I had a feeling there was something over here.
I know there's...
I know there's something here.
I know I can feel it.
It all looks normal, but it's not.
It's underneath, pulsing, trying to get out.
Is it trying to get out?
Is it trying to get out, or should I get in?
I have to uncover it.
Rip it to the surface.
I was innocent.
They attacked me first.
They ran after me!
This was all self-defense.
This was literally self-defense.
Oh, what?
Oh, that was an accident.
No!
What the...
Oh my god, this is...
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I'm so fucked up.
I'm so fucked up right now.
No, wrong legs.
Wrong legs.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, I used so many... I used so many resources there.
I didn't think they would fucking...
Oh my god, I didn't think they would come after me like that.
They saw what I did to the other girls.
They saw what I did.
Oh my god, I need to use two?
How fucked up did they made me?
Oh, these women...
They ain't playing no more, guys.
They are not playing no more.
Oh no.
Oh no, they're not playing, guys.
They're not playing no more, chat.
They know what they want.
Oh, okay.
They have to be on the other side.
They're mad.
They're so fucking mad.
There's a note.
I was wrong.
Wrong, wrong.
No, I wasn't.
But I was entirely right.
I need to peel off more something.
Something more blood clothes.
It has to be here.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh, I fucking...
I fucking knew it.
I knew you were hiding something.
I knew you were hiding.
I knew it.
Hellfire.
Be gone, woman.
Alright, let's see.
How do I get there?
Was it just Lou here?
Is that it?
Is there nothing else?
There's a crawl space.
This?
I don't even get past that.
There's a bed?
What the fuck?
Where the fuck am I supposed to go?
I'm so confused.
Like, where am I?
Where do I go?
I thought...
Is this a dead end?
What's the point of going here?
What the fuck was the point?
Crawl?
Just in case I...
I can't.
Guys, I know you're fucking with me.
There's no way I can crawl.
There's no crawl button.
What?
Go back?
There's no way.
Oh my god, I have to press E.
I had to press E.
Oh my god, LaCroix.
Let me grab...
Let me grab me some fucking LaCroix real quick.
Oh my god, I had to press E.
Alright, I have this now.
I guess I throw my canned juice.
Goodbye, juice.
Yay!
Oh, I fixed it!
My LaCroix!
No!
Why did she do that?
Is she stupid?
Alright, how do I go back?
How do I get back down?
Okay.
Oh, I don't like that sound.
Oh, he's here.
Where do I go?
Is there anything over here?
I never went this way.
Hello?
Any freaks?
No freaks?
Alright.
No freaks.
No freaks ready.
Anybody wanna freak out?
Any hot single freaks in the area?
Oh my god, my heart, man.
My fucking heart.
Like...
God damn it.
Okay.
Yes.
Is there a shortcut here?
Oh, nice ammo.
What was this?
Where am I?
Oh, okay.
That's a shortcut.
Okay.
Okay, I was like...
Where the fuck am I?
I'm so confused.
Where's the medallion?
Wait, where the...
Where the fuck is the coin?
Where is it?
Where could it fall?
Who stole it?
Who the fuck stole it?
Who the fuck stole the coin?
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Oh my god, it's all the way there.
It's actually so far.
Why was the coin so fucking far?
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Why the fuck was the coin so far?
Alright, back into the coin hole you go.
I know it's not the right order, guys.
But like, there's so many coins and I just want to put it there.
I...
I just want...
I just...
I just want to put it there for now.
Alright.
Where am I supposed to go now?
I guess I could look into the rooms?
On the very...
I need three more.
Oh, I only need one more?
Where is the last coin?
Chat?
Where is it?
Is that the bottom floor?
It's in the...
There's a fucking pool?
What the fuck?
I guess it's the Rosewater Park, right?
It has to be the pool.
Yeah, it should be back here.
Okay, here we go.
Here we fucking go.
Alright.
Hello?
Any pool boys or pool ladies in my area too?
Huh?
Who's coughing?
The fuck?
Hello?
Who's you?
Did you see a child?
I have something to...
I never forgot about her.
Like, why are you here?
Why are you here?
Who are your monsters, Eddie?
Unless Eddie is like my subconscious.
You're not from here?
How'd you get here?
How'd you get to Silent Hill?
Me?
What?
Look, I'm just trying to be friendly.
He won't think I'm weird if I wear the mask.
He'll think I'm like not one of the monsters.
Yeah!
No, I want an ally.
What do you mean no?
James, we need an ally!
You can literally find people to get...
Yeah, it makes me more approachable, chat.
What do you mean?
James, we could find some...
Wait, I have a collar on.
Oh, it's that type of mask.
And that closed the door on it.
Look how it closed the door.
I was like, alright, enough of that.
No more looking at that for you.
I just didn't even want to look at it.
I can't believe I closed the fucking door.
I'm just like, well, I'm done.
My day here is over.
I did my job.
Alright, out of the window we go.
Yippee!
Oh, hey, there's a pula.
Oh, shit.
Okay,
let me get rid of this guy first.
Let me shoot him in the ass.
We didn't see that.
We didn't see that guy.
Okay, okay.
There's the pula.
Look, I just wanted to shoot him in the butt.
Is he gonna run at me?
No!
What?
You double...
You triple tap, you whore.
You...
I should've just shot you.
That's it, I'm not dealing with this anymore.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll kill these guys first.
Oh, what?
Okay.
I didn't realize he gets up, guys.
That was my mistake.
But I will not make mistakes no more.
I will not make the same mistake no more!
Alright, there should be the medallion.
Yay!
We did it.
Alright.
Apparently he hugs.
Now we know.
How do I get out of here?
Okay, not this way.
What's this say?
This gate is open from...
Guys, does anyone know what time it is?
Alright.
Oh, I wasted so much.
I wasted so much for that though.
Okay.
Just wanna make sure I got everything.
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, thank god this is back here.
Oh, thank god it loop-de-looped.
Okay.
Soon...
First sits the maiden underneath the tree.
The wind from behind the maiden doth blow.
So sleek in the eyes.
Okay, then it's here.
Wait, where the fuck does the snake go?
What?
That's a snake.
Oh!
Sorry, I didn't realize you could flip the coin.
Alright.
The man doth approach his blade.
Now revealed, his face disappears behind.
Away from the man doth the maiden flee.
Towards the flower, away from the tree.
Oh, okay.
Here.
That not it?
Here?
Here.
Oh, no, no, no.
Running towards the flower!
The fuck?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's away from the tree.
His face disappears.
She's not underneath the tree anymore.
Away from the tree.
The fuck?
She's not dead!
It's not a snake!
Where else would it be?
Do we put it here?
I don't understand.
That's the sword!
Oh my god, please.
Where
could it be?
Where could it be?
I literally have every combination possible!
Think hard.
The man doth approach his blade.
The blade now revealed.
His face disappears behind the shining steel.
Away from the man doth the maiden flee.
Towards the...
I swear to god I'm heading towards it.
Like, she's running!
That's the sword!
How stupid am I?
Like, she's not dead!
Her face is right there!
What?
Oh my god, what?
I don't understand.
I...
I don't...
Okay.
Where once a venomous glee.
Where once was a maiden, but a stone.
And over her grave.
There we go.
Okay.
The beast who its teeth in her flesh doth bore.
He who has felled, she who is no more.
Now on to you fall.
What?
The beast who its teeth in her flesh doth bore.
He who has felled, she who is no more.
Oh, okay!
I didn't realize.
Okay.
Flesh doth bore.
He who has felled, she who is no more.
Now on to you falls a grievous chore.
Who carries...
Well, obviously the snake, right?
Yeah.
That is...
Okay, I did it.
It was the snake.
Oh my god.
I...
I didn't understand the second one.
The second one fucked me up.
I still don't understand.
I...
I still don't understand the second one.
Okay.
I have to go to 200, so I have to go up.
I didn't understand the second one, chat.
I didn't understand.
Is this way?
Yeah.
I'm scared.
Oh...
201.
What do I do in 201?
Hello?
Why is this so nice?
Oh, thank god.
There is heals.
Why is this a nicer area?
Oh, nevermind.
Nevermind.
Oh
my god.
It's him.
It's me.
They didn't remove the seed.
No!
This is what happens when my desires...
James, no.
Don't watch this.
Just because you think you can't doesn't mean you should.
What the fuck?
He's just like, did you like what you see?
Round two.
What the fuck?
He has a fucking...
Road!
My bullets!
James!
Do you know how hard it was to get those bullets?
Minus three bullets.
No more watching privileges.
Sorry.
Sorry for ruining the moment.
James, you fucked up.
He took away...
He took away the privilege, James.
He took it away.
Oh,
shit.
This one has an ass.
Alright.
Let's see this way.
Why is it kicked up?
You know why, James.
You know why.
Oh, I have to go to the other side?
Alright, now I'm here.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I lost my three bullets because James couldn't share.
James didn't want to share no more.
Where the fuck?
I don't even have a map for this, James.
We're in uncharted territory now.
Oh, I don't even have a map.
James, where the fuck do I go, James?
Oh, there's the map.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, this is extra rusty.
Right.
Which one is the map?
Which one is the save point room?
Let's find out.
Oh, not there.
Hello.
Oh.
Oh, that's a longer range.
Hello.
Oh, he has...
What?!
Okay, I don't like this one.
Alright.
Now I know.
The spiky one.
Are you serious?!
Everything can be wrong with him!
Oh my God.
There's so many that actually use bullets for these guys.
James, this is why you don't waste bullets on Pyramid Head.
Okay, the one with spikes does all that.
Break wall?
Which wall?
This one?
Oh, it is.
Where?
Where do I heal up?
Guys, the thing is...
There is no other way to heal up right now.
I'm stuck here.
Thanks.
Ma'am?
Oh my God, please.
Where are you?
Ma'am?
I literally saw you walk!
You're not fooling anybody!
You were walking!
Oh, there he is.
I see her.
Oh, I see multiple hers.
Alright.
Are these explodey guys?
Yeah, they are.
I am...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm sorry.
It wasn't you.
You weren't the main target.
No!
My bullets!
God damn it.
Oh, thank God.
I'm not punished.
I'm not punished at all.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank God I didn't get punished for my actions.
Oh my God, where the fuck is the... Where the fuck is the save point?
There's a moth area?
I should be coming back here.
Yeah, I am on door for moth.
Where
the fuck is the save point in this God forsaken world?
Oh, thank God.
He asked and they shall give.
Thank God there's a save point.
Thank fucking God.
I thought I'd be trapped here forever.
Oh my God.
East, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As a fellow James, we don't like to share.
Henry fears Scott.
He'll run from him and hide.
He's fled to the west on the other side.
But here comes Mildred with unknown intent.
Scott lies face down, blind to her descent.
No, I'm... No, nothing is okay right now.
No, absolutely nothing.
I just want to know, chat, how...
How long is the... is the...
Oh, hey, Scott.
How... Oh, something said...
How long is the apartment's part?
How fucking long will I be trapped in the apartment?
Alright, we need to find the clock keys.
Camera, save one more time.
Oh my God, get me out.
Somebody get me out of here.
Somebody get me out of the fucking apartment, please.
Somebody call the technician.
Okay, well at least there's ammo here.
I want to be outside.
Someone give me the outside world again, that's...
Oh shit, the fuck?
No, my light.
Whoa!
It's not cool.
You can't just turn off my light like that.
That's rude.
That's fucking rude, ma'am.
It's not cool.
Hey, here.
Oh, there's a dog.
Oh, there's... I got to break this.
Okay, I got to break this wall.
I was polite, I called her ma'am.
Oh, hey, a big... Oh, hey, yeah, let's put bullets with the baby.
Stupid bug.
I can't believe the bug got me.
Are you fucking serious?
The bug actually got me.
They baited me with the baby!
I got baited!
I saw the baby and I was like, hehe.
I just have to be sure.
Because if they explode, I don't want to get near them.
Oh, nice.
More ammo.
Oh, thank God, they're giving me so much ammo.
Thank fucking God.
I needed this.
God, I wish they gave me more ammo.
Heels.
I need less of that and more of the fucking heels.
Where do I go?
Where am I?
This is locked.
Why'd they take me upstairs?
Please make sense.
I need you to make sense.
Why am I out here?
Break the window?
I can do that?
Vandalism?
No, you guys were wrong.
Climb?
Where?
Is that a ladder?
Oh!
Guys, it wasn't yellow.
I couldn't tell.
Guys, I can only read in yellow.
Oh, wait.
He was here.
I was here.
Pyramid Head was here.
Guys, I can't read in... I can't... I can only read in yellow, guys.
You know that.
Do I have to kill Pyramid Head?
Okay.
Oh, I'm getting really scared now.
I'm getting really scared, chat.
I don't like this.
I don't like all the... I don't like all the dead bodies here.
Is there?
There's so many dead bodies.
Why is there so many?
I don't know which way to go.
There's so many of you.
Ah!
Alright.
My fucking toe touched it.
My goddamn toe touched his stupid puke.
I can't believe my big toe.
My fucking big ass toe fucked me up.
I don't know what...
Oh, this area is so confusing to me.
Oh, nice.
More bullets.
There's something on the other side.
Oh my god, I'm so filled with fear right now.
Okay, shortcut.
Why is there a shortcut like this?
Like, what?
Oh, they're all gonna come alive, aren't they?
They're all gonna come alive.
That's why there's a shortcut like this.
Oh, that's why.
It makes so much more sense.
That's why.
Oh, I know it.
I fucking know it.
Oh, I fucking know it.
They're all gonna come alive.
That's why it's like that.
That's why.
Makes you loop the loop.
There's a wall?
Where?
Oh, there it is.
This one?
Is this a shortcut?
Yeah, it is.
I feel like they're all gonna come alive and I'm supposed to run away from them.
I feel it.
That's why there's so many loop-de-loop areas.
I can read the script right now.
Oh my god, I feel the script right now.
I know what they wanna do!
What the fuck?
Oh, what?
Is that TV?
Okay.
What's that doing over there?
What are all these doing over there?
I
got...
and now there's another...
Oh my god.
Okay, here we go.
What?
Oh, the window closed.
Oh!
I was like, what happened?
What happened?
Okay, I guess I'll raise the pressure.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh god, please.
Get out!
No!
Please.
Oh my god.
Bro, that was so... oh my god.
Please, that was so much of my HP.
That was so much of my HP.
You guys suck!
What key did I get?
I don't even remember what key I got.
306, okay.
Okay.
That was so much of my HP, chat.
Oh.
Oh, she's ballerina now.
Wait, has she always been ballerina?
Okay, now she has ballerina shoes.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, my heart.
My heart.
My fucking heart right now.
Oh, it's the regular ones.
It's the regular ones.
It's not the extra freaky ones.
That's fine!
No!
Oh no.
Oh my... guys, remember when I had 30 bullets?
Me too, I remember.
I remember when I had 30 bullets, guys.
Bro, there's not enough room.
There's only so little room, man!
There's only so little room!
Like, please!
Oh, my head has the bullet count?
I had 30 at one point.
And then life was like... has a sick way of being like...
JK.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I just... I didn't want to risk it, man.
I just didn't want to risk it, bro.
She just walked up to me and I was like, self-defense.
I plead self-defense!
Alright.
I missed a photo?
What photo?
Where could it be?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
There's a little photo?
There is not a photo.
That's just blood.
Okay, what do I have?
I have the valve.
And I go back to 307.
I just run.
Like, I don't know what else to do.
Oh, shit!
Alright, that's just a regular guy.
Alright, there you go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
To the right we go.
Oh yeah, you're not dead.
I think I don't know a thing when I see one!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, get out here!
The second cockroach!
He was like, oh my god, I want to join in.
He's just like, is this a party?
And I wasn't invited?
When you find out the cockroach can fly.
Everyone decides to join in.
Alright.
Did I do it?
Oh, I got the key!
Oh, I got the hour hand!
Nice.
Oh, that must be a shortcut out.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I don't remember where the- is this the save point area?
Oh my god, it is.
Oh, thank god.
Please.
Oh my god, we made it all the way here.
We made it back.
Alright.
I don't fucking know what that is.
Is that where it's pointing at?
Alright, now where do I go?
Do I have any other items?
Alright, we're gonna call it here.
That's enough for my brain today.
That's enough for my brain.
That's enough for today.
There.
Oh my god.
My brain was just like...
My brain was literally like flatlining there and then I'm like, you know what?
It's a good time to stop.
Puzzle, puzzle detect.
Guys, I already did two puzzles.
I don't know if I can do the third.
I don't know if a third puzzle is gonna hit the spot, guys.
The thinking cap has been reached.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good job getting through the American ghost to a gun range during ammo shortage.
Emotional experience.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, did you get top 500 Overwatch 2 this season or do you owe Paladin and James a debt?
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, wait.
How many days left do I have of the season?
Guys, I actually... What was the bet that I made?
There was so many things going on, guys.
Guys, double or nothing next season.
I'll get it, guys, guys.
Negotiate.
Double or nothing, I'll get it next season.
And if I don't, if I don't, you guys, you guys cannot.
Double or nothing next season.
I'll do it.
I'll do it next season.
There was just a lot of stuff going on.
But this time, this time it'll be different, guys.
Double or nothing.
Don't worry.
Like, don't worry.
Guys, double or nothing.
I promise you guys, next season.
If I don't get it next season, then, then you guys can claim your prize.
I have an excuse.
I was sick, chat.
I was so sick, guys.
Paladin, please.
Please.
Please, please, Paladin.
Double or nothing, please.
I'll do anything.
If I don't get top 500, you can request anything.
You can literally request anything in your dreams.
It will be yours if you give me double.
No, no, not now.
Not now.
Please, Paladin.
I swear, next season, if I don't do it, you get anything you ever want.
Anything.
I told my teacher that when I was, this is my homework.
I was sick.
Angela, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, please.
Oh, I have another excuse.
Guys, my voice.
Oh, my voice, guys.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
My voice.
I can barely talk anymore.
I need a rest.
I can barely, barely talk.
JL, anything.
Paladin, you have the power.
Think about it, Paladin.
Think about it.
Just think about it, guys.
Paladin, come on.
You can request anything you want if I don't make it next season.
It's a double or nothing, Paladin.
The world is your oyster.
Guys, I would never lie.
After giving you the example.
After proving to you guys what lying can get you.
I would never lie.
I would never do such a thing.
Don't worry.
It's literally one more hour.
No, you don't understand.
This game scares the shit out of me.
You don't understand.
This game is so fucking scary.
You want a contract?
I will fucking fine.
I'll fucking... Okay, here we go.
This is the contract.
Do we have any lawyers?
Do we have any Dragoon lawyers in chat?
Double or nothing.
Overwatch top 500 next season.
Paladin gets anything.
There we go.
Okay, we have a law student.
That's almost.
This will be your first job.
Alright.
And then...
There we go.
And I'll sign for you too.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I'll sign for you.
Don't worry.
I got you.
And then a lawyer can look at this and confirm for me.
Alright, the moment the lawyer confirms for me, then it is official.
There we go.
The left side is your signature.
Thank you for signing it.
Doki can't be trusted since she banned a guy because she didn't like...
No!
I banned him because he lied.
That's different.
That's so different.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
One of the things I've always admired about you is your willingness to follow through with bets and bargains with your chat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Alright, paladin.
Do we have a deal?
Give me a handshake right now.
Handshake right now.
Come on.
You know what you want.
This is such a good deal.
Come on.
Here we go.
I have my hand out.
Paladins, I have...
Come on.
Give me the other hand, paladins.
It's right there.
It's...
Come on.
You know you want to shake the hand.
Give me the other hand.
Come on, paladin.
Just shake the hand.
Just...
Just shake the hand, paladin.
Come on.
Right there.
No, no, no.
You...
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait.
No, no, no.
No, paladin.
Come on.
You know you want to.
Just put the other hand.
Put...
Put the other hand in there.
You know you want to.
Don't listen to the haters.
Listen to your oshi.
Toki, I can't believe you pulled the oshi card like that.
I can't believe it.
Where are you, paladins?
Where are you?
Where is he?
I don't see him.
I don't see his response.
No, he didn't say no.
He didn't say...
That's emotional blackmail.
I don't see you.
Paladins, just put that hand there.
You know?
That's all you have to do.
Just put your hand there.
Just put that...
Oh my god!
That's fucked.
But you know what's more fucked?
Oh, you're gonna regret this, paladin.
Oh, you're gonna...
You're gonna regret this.
Because look what I found.
Look what I found.
He shook his hand.
It's over.
Hand has been shook.
Thank you for accepting the deal.
Wow, paladins.
Thank you so much.
For...
For accepting that deal.
I really...
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm so happy that you decided to double or nothing the arrangement that we had.
I really...
I really appreciate it, paladins.
For giving me that handshake in the end.
And letting me...
Letting us do a double or nothing.
How do you know?
How do you know that's not his hand?
He literally wrote that down.
He wrote this down, chat.
How would you know?
JL, I so look forward to Doki's stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wow.
Anyway, guys.
Thank you.
Huge shout out to paladins.
For agreeing to this double or nothing.
And then shaking my hand.
For this arrangement.
And as his oshi.
I shall honor this deal.
For the double or nothing.
It was a great time.
I had a great time today, guys.
I had a great time.
That's not his hand.
Oh, yeah?
How do you know that, Mike?
You have never seen his hand before?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You don't know that.
We don't have a supreme court here to challenge me.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody.
Say hi.
Photoshop this.
What?
Darkblade!
Darkblade.
I can't believe you would...
I can't believe you would say such a thing.
Give me like...
Oh, my gosh.
I can't...
I can't believe you would...
Say such a thing.
Darkblade.
How could you say that?
How...
How could you say such a thing?
I don't understand.
I don't understand what you're talking about, guys.
I would never...
I would never use Photoshop.
But like...
Yeah, no, you're right.
You're right, Darkblade.
I am a doki bird.
I don't know.
You're right, Darkblade.
I am a doki bird, though.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She hated him because he said the truth.
Also, truth, to be fair.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I went to University of America.
American Samoa.
Exactly!
We have lawyers confirming.
Guys, we have lawyers confirming.
Momohaku.
Obviously, she's...
What forgery are you talking about?
What forgery?
She took chat away.
Now, nobody can confirm anything.
No more.
I don't even have...
Even chat disappeared.
Even chat...
There we go.
Look at that.
See?
I'm a doki bird.
Anyway, guys.
I'm gonna head off now.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you sit up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
Jay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I know a good lawyer, guys.
Don't worry.
Guys, don't worry.
I know a very good lawyer for you guys.
And I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!